one of the things i'm always trying to
fight is this idea that like technology
is a cold weird thing or that
mass-produced items whether it's a
blender a car or a computer are simply
dead things within themselves like the
humans once they get their hands on the
things love the things and their love of
the things make these things come alive
so there is a benefit in collecting
things right because there's a a part of
you that comes in there it becomes part
of the story of your life the story you
tell it becomes the talisman um
and and here's the thing right so when i
was in my teens i started calling
computer bulletin board systems
and i loved them
i racked up incredible amounts of bills
this is another yearbook photo uh where
i am posing with my bbs
so yeah
that's right and you're like wow jason
you also have some weird stuff in there
yes cryptographic message uh how to make
chicken littles from a kfc that one of
my friends worked at lysol there's a
whole thing with
there's a whole thing with shop vacs and
that's why that's there the dust buster
i made sure that i had a dust buster in
every photo of me in the yearbook i
don't know
sometimes i think like there'd just be
this glowing door and i come out and go
what are you thinking and then leave
again
no advice no nothing just stop it but
you know anyway dust busters love them
um but the thing was was when i called
bulletin board systems and i'm assuming
people know what a bulletin board system
is a bulletin board system is basically
a computer with a modem with a lonely
person at it who then
um keeps code up so that when other
lonely people call them they leave
messages about how angry they are at the
world because they're lonely and then
other people disagree with them and
nobody gives anybody a hug
and
um anyway so the point is that these
things were kind of self-made worlds
right you would you would pay enormous
amounts of money at the time to put a
computer on a phone line i mean this is
all very expensive and then other people
would call and use your computer and
post it but the thing was is that they
were transient right they were
unbelievably transient they would go
away after like five six months and and
some of them would stay around for a
year or two or disappear
jason who had previously learned that
the world was messed up would back up
everything he found so if i found
anything on the website that i liked
that uh told me about uh the place or
had quote unquote text files where you
could go and find out how to make a bomb
how to fix a modem how to
angry at the world 10 terrible light
bulb jokes i just grabbed them all right
i just grabbed them all and put them all
on floppy disks until i had a stack of
floppy disks uh and when bulletin board
systems stopped being important in my
life
okay that's not right when bulletin
board system stopped being a thing i did
daily i ended up going to you know
college and i found a way to go on
through mit system into the internet at
like 18 or 19 and you know once you
once you're doing you know the heroin
it's hard to go back to the marijuana
and so
i ended up um storing away those
floppies
and
in 1998
i thought man i sure had fun on those
bbs's now i'm 28
and the web is up and the web has
everything now
um it's got alta vista it's it's pretty
it's got lots of
the text will center now you can affect
the font um
sky's the limit so let me go look up
about my favorite bulletin board system
sherwood forest
914-359-157 and let's go find out what's
going on with them no information that's
weird
how about bulletin board systems of new
york nothing
how about bulletin board systems not
much
all right what happened here now
friggin 20 years of research has
revealed to me what happened i'll tell
you in a moment it's not that
interesting but
basically bulletin board systems were
persona non grata on internet
and so i was like but i have all these
old text files
well why don't i put them all up
so so i ended up grabbing textfiles.com
and i put up 50 000 text files that i
collected over those years and all these
people came out of the woodwork to go
first oh my god all these old things
and more importantly i have stuff and i
don't want it
you obviously do
would you like the stuff now and i'm
like yes yes please send me the stuff
send me cd-roms send me piles of floppy
send me whatever you want to and i'll
put them up on
textfiles.com and textfiles.com grew and
grew and grew and and i became known
whether i wanted to
as a historian as an archivist as a
librarian
i did not go to school for these things
i went to school with a film degree
okay i graduated from high school this
is very true this is not me being funny
i graduated from high school with a 1.7
grade point average
all right
that is very hard to do without shooting
the place up
but i did it i did it
you